même si hier on vient de faire votre
emplacement totale de la hanche droite
on finira après une quinzaine de minutes
et vous de la douleur c'est la deuxième
manche que madame soulière se fait
remplacer la première intervention était
difficile mais celle ci se présente
mieux nous capables de bouger la jambe
montrez nous voir fait plier comme il
faut pas refaire le pied bouge bien
z'avez pas de malaise de est-ce que vous
avez des nausées voire un patient
sourire après une chirurgie orthopédique
peut surprendre mais pour le docteur
venditelli et son équipe c'est presque
routinier depuis 2006 ils ont développé
un nouveau protocole de remplacement de
la hanche et du genou dont les résultats
sont souvent spectaculaires
beaucoup de patients chez qui on a opéré
avec une technique standard et la
nouvelle technique nous rapporte
unanimement que c'était grave à une
grande amélioration pour unis parce
qu'on n'a pas fait la même opération
au départ ils se sont attaqués aux
effets secondaires causés par la
puissante médication employé durant une
intervention classique entre autres les
opioïdes
quand on a des procédures existent
depuis plusieurs années tu fonctionne
bien mais qui ont des effets secondaires
sont lire questionne pas on sait pas
aujourd'hui la situation est beaucoup
plus légère et le bas du corps des
patients restent mobile qu'on s'est
rendu compte qu'on a pu diminuer la
quantité de piétons de nos patients puis
privilégier les médicaments qui avait
pas d'effets secondaires ou très peu
résultat à peine 13 % des patients
opérés avec le nouveau protocole se sont
plaints de douleurs postopératoires
contre 67 % avec l'ancienne approche
même chose avec les autres effets
secondaires cours un monsieur miville
nos verts par exemple s'est fait opérer
l'an passé tout de suite après
l'intervention ou d'infirmer à
l'encourager à monter et à redescendre
une dizaine de marches 15 arrivée au pas
de lien à faire avec bolt si vous les
interrogez vous à la maison
les jours suivants il ne prend aucun des
instituts là qu'on lui propose
les derniers me demander si j'ai fait là
tous les deux
c'était contenu utile c'est quoi c'est
la douleur djich pour le nouveau
protocole modifie également certaines
pratiques chirurgicales notamment elle
prévoit l'infiltration d'anesthésiques
locaux et une nouvelle façon de refermer
la plaie en bout de ligne tout ça
diminue le temps d'hospitalisation du
patient pour la hanche
elle dure maintenant quelques heures
plus tôt que trois jours et pour le
genou 24 heures au lieu de cinq jours
j'étais surpris puis les gens autour de
moi autant sauter opéré à la hanche en
mars dernier stéphane bern ni un
travailleur de la construction a
récupéré très rapidement
c'est un autre des études du protocole
accélérer le retour à une vie normale
à la maison je passe l'aspirateur avec
une béquille puis l'aspirateur dans
l'autre main à six semaines je
recommence à travailler je faisais je
fais de la rénovation je fais que je
faisais une salle de bain je tente
l'industrie paie une salle de bains est
seul au final la nouvelle approche
médicale permet d'économiser en moyenne
1400 dollars par opération de la hanche
et plus de 4000 pour le genou une
chirurgie de remplacement de la hanche
il ya 25 ans apprenait trois heures les
gens restaient une semaine à l'hôpital
donc des gains ont un cours de au cours
des années et on pense que ce qu'on a
obtenu aujourd'hui c'est un gros gros
gain pour les patients qui la société
l'équipe de maisonneuve rosemont
travaille maintenant à implanter son
approche partout au pays